Alphabet,
Google's parent company and owner of the
Youtube platform visit,
negotiating to build a technology center
in none other than Saudi Arabia.
Sounds incredible,
but the truth is that since Mohammed bin
Salman,
the crown prince takeover this country
has started to change a lot,
at least much more than everyone would
have imagined just a few years ago.
So us today.
Let's have a look at what exactly is
happening in Saudi Arabia.
Do you understand what's happening in
Saudi Arabia?
We need to take a look at that past to
see where everything began.
Well,
first of all,
we need to bear in mind that we're
talking about a particularly young
country.
Saudi Arabia was formally born in 1932.
Then of course Saudi Arabia was really
different to how it is today.
You see,
back then,
many oil deposits hadn't yet been
discovered,
so it was a very poor place that still
had a spouse,
semi nomadic population.
The Saudi Arabia was still kind of in
the Middle Ages.
Now that I think about it,
really a lot of things have actually
changed that much,
but a few years later in 1938,
the first oil deposits were discovered
and since then,
well,
let's just say that the house of sounds
of the country's royal houses used oil
to make Arabia look like the United
States,
at least in terms of aesthetics and
leisure.
Well,
allow me to explain myself.
We're talking for example,
of cities inspired by Dallas' driving
American cars and building huge moles in
the middle of the desert and that's
exactly what they did for decades.
That's not only that.
Over the years the Saudi government you
thanks aisle has begun to have a lot of
money.
You can do it kind of agreements with
Washington that has lasted more or less
until today.
So check out disagreements.
Saudi Arabia generates a huge and
relatively cheap oil supply using the
dollars.
It's basic currency.
I mean,
you've probably heard of petro dollars
and accumulate all the money,
generates an oil sales in us treasury
debt or in the Big Wall Street banks,
and if that weren't enough,
the Saudi government is always willing
to inject millions into the powerful US
owns industry.
That is,
that is
lots of oil,
lots of money and great business for the
US military industry.
So the question becomes,
well,
in exchange for watts,
who basically for protection,
the house of Saudi bought what
essentially amounts to insurance from
Washington to protect it from foreign
enemies.
However,
in 1979,
everything changed.
You see,
19,
79 was a fundamental year for Arabian
countries.
And for Islam on the one hand to Islamic
revolution happens in Iran.
And on the other hand,
the Soviet Union invaded Afghanistan.
And in Saudi Arabia,
between November the 20th and December
the fourth,
a group of fanatics took over the Great
Mosque of Maca and accuse the house of
Southie,
Saudi monarchy of betraying Islam and
selling their soul to the west fanatics
called for an uprising to overthrow the
royal family.
And that if you are is where everything
changed,
the house of Saudi leaders feared a
revolutionary uprising and decided to
please the extremists.
The United States could certainly
protect them from the foreign enemy,
but it will be very hard for them to do
soak in a popular uprising like the one
that happened in Iran.
So even though this part of the world
wasn't exactly a paradise of freedom
from that Bermans on,
things got a lot,
lot worse.
Discrimination against women reached
stratospheric levels,
they religious.
God began an uncontrolled campaign and
Saudi Arabia began to finance all kinds
of extremist groups like there was no
tomorrow,
both inside and outside of the country.
And that's precisely the Saudi Arabia.
We'll know how we'll just waste a moment
because there was another turning point
in 2015 this time thanks to you
plummeting oil prices in the arrival of
a new King Salman Bin Abdulaziz.
Great flavor overall.
This is a king who decided to give
almost all the power to his son.
And now his APP,
Muhammad Bin Salmaan of here.
We already talked about here on visual
politic before.
That's a new generation,
took a hold of the country.
My generation was held hostage by 1979.
I know now that my kids will not be
hostages,
one Saudi banker to the New York Times.
Since then,
folks,
a new kind of revolution has been
launched to modernize the country.
We've already talked about this on this
channel,
but the truth is that the plan is
advancing at full speed and it's based
on three pillars.
The fight against corruption,
economic change,
and religious reform.
So without further ado,
well,
let's see what's happening.
Point by point.
Saudi Arabia is anti corruption
crackdown.
Saudi Arabia detailing 11,
nearly 60 detainees,
uh,
promptly removed.
We're being told,
sure.
Fight against corruption
the ground.
Brent's has said it both actively and
passively.
Corruption in Saudi Arabia is a great
burden added,
has to rent.
Our country has suffered a lot from
corruption from the 19 eighties until
today.
The calculation of our experts is that
roughly 10 percent of all government
spending was siphoned off by corruption
each year from the top levels to the
bottom.
Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman,
as you know,
was as it was said,
so it was done last November,
that's 2017 prince's businessmen,
ministersx,
politicians,
and a huge number of people were invited
to dine with the king or to meet with
the crown prince.
Of course,
only in a country like Saudi Arabia that
we would see a prison like this.
This is the Ritz Carlton at reacts a
very,
very luxurious hotel.
Of course,
nos.
Everything was comfortable after all,
it became a prison that held such
illustrious prisoners as Prince Alwaleed
bin Talal grandson of the kingdoms own
founder,
known as the Warren Buffett of the
Middle East.
This is a prince who,
according to Forbes magazine,
has a fortunate to have almost
$18,000,000,000 in just one of twitter's
largest shareholders.
Well,
not even he,
even with all this money managed to
escape all the prisoners were held
incommunicado and couldn't even contact
their lawyers rights.
Legal guarantees.
Come on,
we're in Saudi Arabia,
but what do you think the Saudi
government asked for to release them?
Well,
nothing less than giving part of their
fortunes and companies as compensation
for all the corruption that they were
involved in as well.
Here's a question.
Do you know how much the Saudi
government raised with this trick?
This up,
because this is an astounding number.
It wasn't one or five or 10 billion,
but it was approximately an one popping
$107,000,000,000.
Of course,
a few detractors have accused the crown
prince of carrying out this campaign,
not with the intention of fighting
corruption class with the aim of
strengthening his power.
For example,
seizing control of the foreign based
media.
Yes,
the detainees included important media
businessmen bots have you at this
doesn't end here also at all the
economic change as we've mentioned on
visual politics.
Saudi Arabia wants to emulate Dubai and
leave their dependence on oil behinds
and they want to do it hand in hand with
private capital just as we saw in
Google's case.
Of course,
on the other hand,
as Prince Mohammed bin Salman is also
very fond of big projects.
The last one he publicized was Naomi
Macro city that the government wants to
build in the Red Sea next to Jordan and
Egypt.
Check out some of these numbers,
500 $500,000,000,000 in public and
private investments in order to urbanize
and build a city that is larger in area
than El Salvador.
This is a 10,000 square mile place that
will have its own laws,
its own courts and its own taxes.
This is a new city that the crown prince
wants to turn into a great transport hub
as a huge international business center.
Basically a much more modern and much
bigger Dubai,
and this isn't his only project.
Saudi Arabia plans a huge Red Sea beach
tourism project.
The project will cover 50 islands and
34,000 square kilometers an area bigger
than Belgium and there's a few more.
Prince's idea is to get all these cities
to have laws and standards different
from those in the rest of the country.
Laws they can attract investors,
attract tourists and entrepreneurs.
The question is,
will really be able to make all of these
projects work in a country that is so
anchored in the past.
Awesome.
When he's like that,
it doesn't seem easy at first,
but I suppose we'll see so far.
People like Richard Branson certainly
support the strategy,
the religious change,
sleep.
There's the religious changed,
the princes latest and great obsession
is the struggle against Islamic
fundamentalism or its most radical
interpretations.
You see,
Saudi Arabia is a country of
restrictions,
which is something we probably all know
and it may never cease being so.
However,
just a few years ago,
nobody could have imagined we'd see so
many changes and quite so quickly
concerts and movies which had been bands
have returned to the country.
The religious God has lost almost all of
its power.
Women can now attend sports stadiums and
since June they can also drive.
I go on any further.
On December the sixth,
2017,
the Lebanese singer hereby to start in
Saudi Arabia first.
All female concepts.
Yes.
Even the audience was entirely made up
of women and this is something we
couldn't even have imagined just three
years ago.
Listen to this reflection,
privileged to be the generation that has
seen the before and the after,
the previous generation of Saudi.
Women could never imagine a day when a
woman could drive and the coming
generation will never be able to imagine
a day when a woman couldn't.
A 30 year old Saudi woman social
entrepreneur to the New York Times.
The person in charge of this entire
process is Mohammed bin Salman.
We aren't restoring Islam to its origins
and our biggest tools are the prophets
practices.
At the time of the Prophet Mohammed,
there were musical theaters.
There was mixing between men and women.
There's a SPEC for Christians and Jews
and Arabia.
The first commercial,
Judge Medina was a woman.
So if the profit embrace all of this,
do you mean the profit was not a Muslim
crown?
Prince Mohammed bin Salman
for a Saudi Arabian data to say
something like this,
while the only word is wow,
and by the way,
don't think that Saudi Arabia was always
the place it was in the past.
Of course,
it was always a very,
very conservative country to
conservative.
Certainly not the hell that it became in
1979.
The short,
as you can see,
even though there's still a lot to
change,
things seem to be on the right track.
Although of course there are certainly
still dark areas.
He Qatar,
blockade failure,
the Yemen war and the princess obsession
with Taran ran
team leader is the new Hitler of the
Middle East,
but we learned from Europe that
appeasement doesn't work.
We don't want the new Hitler in Iran to
repeat what happened in Europe in the
Middle East,
Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman.
This prince is a take charge kind of
man,
but to tell the truth so far,
his international attempts have been
resounding failures as we saw with Yemen
and other problem is that the Arabic
countries,
economies are going from bad to worse.
In 2017,
they suffered that first recession since
2009 and public deficit is still
skyrocketing,
growing by more than $50 million dollars
every year,
and of course that can make it hard for
the prince to carry out his plants.
In any case,
having seen this,
I think we can say that the oil was some
of the best news for everyone,
especially for Saudi Arabian women,
turning to what we have done before,
a country of moderate Islam that is open
to all religions and to the world.
We will not spend the next 30 years of
our lives dealing with destructive
ideas.
We will destroy them today.
We will end extremism very soon.
Mohammed bin Salman.
Anyway,
that's how things are,
but now it's your turn.
Do you think Saudi Arabia will manage to
change itself?
Well,
leave your answer in the comments below
as well as in this survey and I really
hope you enjoyed this video.
Please do hit that like button if you
did and don't forget to subscribe to our
channel for brand new videos every
Monday and Thursday.
Also,
don't forget to check it off.
Friends,
reconsider media podcasts.
They provided the vocals in this episode
that we're not mine,
and as always,
thank you for what.